we're announcing today that were taking
a first stab at reinventing the inbox so
when you think about the inbox like the
inbox has been the same since the
invention of the first early messaging
systems like even in the really early
early days it's always been this
chronological list of threads and that's
it and that's a lot of real estate on
mobile to use for a thing we're probably
the first five threads are relevant to
you at any given point in time but then
the rest has been taken care of by
really good search and all kinds of
different things and so we're taking a
first step by launching a more modular
inbox that and it's basically called
home so it's your home screen on
messenger and we have units in this new
in box that enables you to get a lot
more utility from your inbox and you
currently get so for instance when using
messenger and this is something we're
starting to roll out today so it'll take
a few days or weeks to for everyone in
this room to have it but you'll be able
to see who's active right now so for a
lot of people actually finding who of
their friends are active on messenger
right now is a great opportunity to have
a conversation if you're bored and you
want to talk to someone you'll have a
unit for birthdays so you'll know which
of your close friends have birthdays
today and you can send them a message
and be a better friend you will have the
ability to also have like a favorites
that favorites unit where you can see
the people you talk to the most so you
can access them really quickly and so
those are first cup of first series of
units inside of the inbox but gradually
you're going to see more of those units
that will enable you to discover the
types of experiences that you might be
able to find on messenger in the future
but also most of your friends at the
right time with the right context